the video you're about to watch
is one of a pseudo-intellectual fraud
an individual who happens to be the
teacher of some of the
main proponents of the anti-islamic
apologetics movement in the west people
like david wood who i have debated
and this individual is known for his
debauchery his
sexual depravity his impiety
this individual has limited intellectual
discourse to offer
and has contributed nothing almost to
the
public discussion or discourse for or
against islam
however what we have noticed about this
individual is that he's a pathological
liar
an individual who is a compulsive liar
cannot help himself but
lie about scripture and about theology
and that's why this individual is
disingenuous
and has been discombobulated
intellectually
is disheveled completely and in fact
in his disconcerted and embarrassed
effort
has nowhere to run and nowhere to hide
from these
um from these points where we have found
him
obviously lying so this is a long video
and i'm sure after about 20 or 30
minutes you'll be able to decide for
yourself
that this individual is definitely a
liar
so this refutation is not one of
necessarily of
academic points since as we will find
there are limited academic points to be
mentioned anyways from his side
but it's of his character of what kind
of individual this is
this guy is a liar and this video is
proof of that
it's a three four hour proof of the lies
this man has concocted and contrived
in his isages of the quranic narrative
and it's a expose of his ignorance
in the fact that this individual is a
ranking naramus
he has no qualifications or training in
the field
and he has no understanding of the
arabic language or even how to read
the quranic text as was proven
the last time we spoke on the phone so
this individual is a fake we have not
even seen his face let alone
been exposed to his qualifications and
so
the problem is of course when you have
someone at the top of the anti-islamic
apologetics movements against islam
who is an ignorant person this does
nothing but
increase the amount of lies that are
propagated against islam
by such individuals as david wood and
his companions and associates i
i'm actually quite bored of doing this i
think this topic has been
overdone i've exposed cp on this
previously but for some odd reason some
folks
and the comments simply cannot see this
so i'm going to do a quick recap plus
share cp's newest lie
about paul perhaps he'll think twice
next time
yeah let me ask you you asked me already
you asked me a question already about
question
christianity let me get your question
you said paul hold on your liar hold on
let me get let me spank you
you said paul is a fake person he never
met jesus
correct let me get you busted hold on
hold on
let me mute you liar filthy
who insult paul because they are
ignorant when paul in the quran is a
messenger of god
did you hear what cp said paul
in the quran is a messenger of god
cp didn't say paul in a quranic
commentary
he said in the quran this is the first
lie
chapter 36 verse number 14 and bingo we
are here
chapter 36 verse 14.
keep that in mind guys this is the first
that supposedly proves that
paul is a messenger of god listen
carefully
everybody read with me carefully chapter
verse number 14. let us see what they
say paul he never met jesus
paul is not even he's a fabricator paul
but their prophet he said
paul is a messenger of allah he is sent
by allah not only that he made
miracles miracles in the name of the
messiah
jesus so who is saying this according to
cp
muhammad peace be upon him said this in
the top of that
their scholars and their prophet they
claim that paul was a messenger of god
who claimed their prophet but yet those
bunch of idiots
nation they claim that paul is a bad
person and he is the one who corrupt
christianity
why your god and your prophet don't
agree with you
explain how come your prophet do not
know about paul that he is a bad person
instead he he make it clear that he is a
messenger of god in the quran
he make it clear that paul is a
messenger
of god in the quran it says
narrated that the following is the names
of the three messengers
from ibn sulaiman from al-ja'abi
the names of the first two messengers
were shamoon
and johanna and the name of the third
was
polos and the city it was entc
why you idiot you keep insulting paul
when the quran
and your scars report him as a messenger
of jesus
and in the same time he is a messenger
of god all right
i think it is quite clear by now cp
is quoting while claiming that paul
is a messenger of god in the quran again
he was not a prophet okay
so let's summarize cp's lies one
paul is a messenger of god in the quran
two the prophet peace be upon him said
that paul is a messenger of allah
three that the prophet said that paul
made miracles in the name of jesus
cp tries to prove this claim
with one a statement by the irrelevant
two a quote by ibn ketia that has
nothing to do with 36 14
which i refuted a couple of days ago on
this channel and three
the following clip where i will expose
his dishonesty again
what's in front of you chapter 36 verse
number 13 and 14.
uh verse number 13 13 or 14.
okay uh can you show it in arabic one my
friend open your quran
so we send we string them with the third
and they said for you we are being sent
yes three messengers okay but it doesn't
say bullos does it
well this is your islamic books
interpretation saying
this will be lie number four cp will now
provide commentary by
lucy for this verse no actually for
another verse
that is completely irrelevant to this
topic
he will be quoting a commentary for
chapter 5.
not chapter 36 but let's just go on to
see where he's gonna go with this
oh okay um yeah anyway let me read for
you no problem
and you can ask any muslim leaders to
read for you anyone who speaks arabic
calling him messenger in his letter to
the king of the romans
all right so the only point here that cp
is
making is that lucy is referring to paul
as bolos which translates to paul the
apostle
now this is absolutely absurd okay
the reason is because referring to paul
as bolus rasul
or paul the apostle doesn't mean that
you believe that he was a messenger or
an apostle
oh no cp look at ali rizvi one of the
most infamous
atheists he apparently is a muslim
and look your best buddy riddhvan is a
muslim too
wow i had no idea
the spirit which means the holy spirit
witness for our soul
we are the children of allah why
and his lovers
the funny thing about this commentary is
that is quoting paul
to prove that he's a heretic paul is
saying
we are the sons of god and his beloved
because if you return to chapter 5
verse 18 you will find allah is refuting
the christians and the jews that make
this claim
so no cp this is not praise for paul
lucy is condemning paul and says
clearly
meaning that allah refuted them for
saying this
cp you have been exposed for lying to
your audience
you pretend that paul is a messenger of
allah according to
and in reality no he's condemning la
luci
guys come on if you can't see it
listen i know you guys hate islam
but be fair there's
admitting that cp is lying about islam
doesn't make islam true you don't have
to believe in islam
but pick your teachers
pick the people that you're going to
follow and that you're going to respect
because this guy doesn't respect you
a person that's going to lie to you
through his teeth
in your face well okay behind the screen
but whatever
you get the idea he's lying to you
multiple
times every video this is one video with
four lies i'm gonna keep on doing this
until you get it until
it gets through your heads that this guy
is lying to you and it doesn't matter
how much you hate islam
you will one day accept this fact
that this guy is lying to you all right
this is this is my challenge this is my
challenge to myself
i'm going to prove to you as even though
even though you will continue to hate
islam
all right this is not about loving islam
this is not about proving islam is true
this is my challenge to myself to prove
to people like you
who hate islam that this man is lying to
you
all right this is my challenge myself
take care of yourselves and
enjoy the show
let me spank you bigger now your ass
will go red
assadam alaikum everybody in my previous
video i shared
four lies by christian prince in today's
video
i'm going to share two more in this clip
cp is using chapter 9 verse 31 to argue
that the quran
teaches that jesus is god now this has
been debunked thoroughly by emin a few
days ago on this channel so
be sure to check that video out in any
case
cp explains to a caller why the quran
would even
include a verse that allegedly
supports the concept that jesus is lord
i believe that this is muhammad he said
that when he was in asara
at that moment he was not really a
muslim
is it correct yes okay
correct oh i'm not sure i believe so
right now you can go to prophet google
peace upon him and search it
khadijah was
all right they will not because nasara
is coming from a christianity supposedly
they are a christian cult
so they will not marry you unless you
are one of them
okay for its adultery to marry someone
from different faith
so you have to be in
himself and this is what happened
so muhammad is saying that you should
those who took their monks are rabbis as
god
instead of the messiah and allah for
they are one god
wow that's quite an explanation
so we have two lies here the first lie
is that the prophet peace be upon him
was a christian
and the second lie is that khadijah was
a christian
one of the reasons that this theory is
quite funny is because
surah number 9 is one of the last
chapters in the quran it was revealed
in the year 8 or 9 after the hijrah 20
years
after the prophet peace be upon him
started teaching islam
a decade after the death of
yeah well as silly and as baseless
as this theory may be i will give
christian prince
a chance to respond so cp
where is the proof that the prophet
peace be upon him and khadijah were
christians
okay so before getting started cp is
attempting to prove to a muslim that
allah
is going to be carried by angels
the muslim that is debating him is not
fond of the idea and argues that the
angels
are actually carrying the throne of
allah not
allah himself now it doesn't matter if
you're eschario or maturity leaning or
if you're a staunch selfie
this video is about cp so keep that in
mind
it says and the angels will be on its
side
actually this is a false translation
will carry it and there will be eight
and they will bear the throne and the
lord will be above them
allah will beware above them okay so the
text doesn't say that
and anyone can read the screen it says
the throne of thy lord above them
okay mafia mushkil sipi english isn't
your first language mafia michigan
let's do this in arabic okay says
yes this means your lord is above them
this is correct but cp is reading a
portion of the verse
the verse doesn't say in a book of
alcohol
meaning the throne of your lord is above
them
and is going to carry in the top of the
throne allah
eight allah is in the top of the train
at the throne
okay no it doesn't doesn't mention allah
it doesn't say that
the word allah the name of allah isn't
isn't in the verse
what a stupid liar
assalamu alaikum boys before starting
this video i'd like to give a big shout
out to granite
is togu i really hope i'm pronouncing
that right in any case
thank you for making my life easier
granite was
kind enough to share this little gem
with me where christian prince
lies around five times within a very
short time span
again thank you granit you're awesome
now on to the clip
this is the volume and this is the story
we are reading from where it says that
if somebody have sex with a
child he will not be punished for having
sex with
the child if i am lying
i want a muslim to get me busted right
now right here
we want to do that
[Laughter]
i am the muslim brave
text says those of sound intellect
do not feel the tendency to have
intercourse with children
that are undesirable and whose bodies
aren't capable of intercourse
due to this there is no prescribed
punishment upon them
so the key word here guys is
had had is a prescribed
punishment now let us see what christian
prince left
out it says here
however he is
punished with an unprescribed punishment
for what the sheri ad did not
permit the key word
here is meaning
to punish with an unprescribed
punishment
so for example let's talk about the
difference between hadden tazir
okay so had is
what happens when someone steals the
head
is the cutting off of the hand um this
is mentioned in the quran
however what is the punishment for
bribery so there's no
prescribed punishment in the quran or
the sunnah
however it's still a haram act that can
be punished
in a court of law thus when a punishment
occurs it is referred to as tazir
so christian prince accuses asaraki
of saying that fornicating with children
is permissible
while he is saying the exact opposite
he's merely saying that islam did not
prescribe the punishment
for those that commit this act however
a punishment is still necessary
the difference is is it prescribed or is
it
unprescribed now saying
it's unprescribed now
cp purposefully avoided the second part
of the sentence
and this is cp's first lie
uh because the the field that the imam
written in his book let islam look like
a
filthy pet of mine no no no no no the
imam is not writing a firth he is
writing
he's not writing first my friend islam
is a is a bad religion this guy is just
in what islam teach
it's not his fault yeah we don't want to
blame the guy
for what muhammad told them you know
this is what islam is about and he is
saying this is what the rules of it
the second lie cp argues that muhammad
peace be upon him taught people that
fornicating
with children is permissible when he
said no such thing
for the geniuses that are about to bring
up alicia
i suggest opening up a dictionary and
looking up the meaning of fornication
and then he says one of the opinions
then he says
and it says there's no penalty and this
is according to the sect the third lie
cp attributes to imam ahmed the view
that fornicating with children has no
penalty
i've expressed in point one that there's
a difference between
and tazir in other words even if a
scholar says that doing a certain
act does not have a head it doesn't mean
that it is not punishable more
importantly
cp reads this section in arabic and
avoids translating it
the statement that cp avoids translating
is most have quoted
imam ahmed saying
even if she is too young for intercourse
which apparently means he does
received a prescribed
punishment so why didn't you translate
this
cp
no penalty for someone he have a sexual
intercourse with a child she is under
the age of nine lie number four
cp quotes a statement about head
while claiming that it means penalty
when reality
it means prescribed punishment
and then it says and
so if a woman this is about a woman now
not only about children who
are female if a woman she did
enter the private part of a male child
under the age of 11
there is no penalty on her too
who is the muslim want to say i'm lying
if a woman
she raped a child under the age of 11
there is no penalty too line number five
again cp quotes a statement about had
while claiming
that it means penalty when in reality it
means
prescribed punishment now
i know what some of you may be thinking
maybe christian prince didn't know that
there's a difference between
had and tazir maybe he's just ignorant
he isn't ignorant these are the basics
and cp is more than qualified
listen to this now you actually went to
university to study
what was the course called was it a
bachelor's degree or three years no yeah
i have a
degree in islamic law i'm qualified to
be a lawyer or a judge in islamic
court or any court in the middle east so
what is a cp
are you lying when you are saying that
no head means no punishment or
are you lying about your qualifications
answer me truthfully he said
today's cp clip was one of the most
disturbing clips for me
i mean by now i'm quite used to
listening to cp lie
but this time it was his victim
and his victim's gullible nature to be
honest
that really got to me a bit of a
background for you guys
this guy that's speaking to cp here is
someone that has doubts about islam
but mainly doubts that revolve around
hadiths
so cp tries to get him to dub the quran
in order to cause his guest more doubts
he quotes chapter 21 verse
81 as we can see there's
nothing here that's all that wild about
this verse
now let's watch the full clip and i ask
you to be
patient before i was most exposed to the
hadith and
it seemed too strange for me and
i didn't want to accept it you know but
when you went into the quran and uh
yeah i cannot defend it you know i
cannot defend it
well if you go to chapter as an example
chapter 21 verse number 18 8182
let me show you
80 21 80
okay let's see
all right
here we see suriman have a flying carpet
but in this flying carpet it can carry
all his kingdom his horses
his cows his donkeys
his chicken army look really
uh and to suriman we subjugated
let me make it bigger okay
all right we subjugated the wind
strongly
dragging means we subjugated the strong
wind to surima
running by his command toward the land
etc and then he says
uh he had a a mat you know what matt
it's like a carpet carpet
he had a carpet or carpet
on which he would place the equipment of
his
kingship horses camels
tents and troops then he would command
the winds
to carry it and he would
it would he would go underneath it which
means the wind
and it would carry him aloft
shading him and protecting him from the
heat
until he reached whenever he want to go
so suriman
anytime we want to go anywhere he
ordered his army to ride
the carpet and then they
after this stand in the top of the car
with him and his horses as you see
camels look equipped everybody was
standing on the
yeah horses camels tents
troops chickens everything you know all
kinds of animals
and then the whole kingdom of life
now how a muslim believe in this
and not only this it says later that
suriman he used to have
600 000 chairs in the top of the carpet
this is for the men so imagine we have
airplane
now in the year 2017 can fly and carry
700 000 traveler
believe it or not cp gets away with it
his guest
doesn't second-guess him and trust the
information that cp provides
cp argues that the quran is absurd while
presenting a narration that isn't even
attributed to the prophet peace be upon
him
while attributing it to the quran and
now he does not make his guest aware of
what he's doing
not surprisingly but wait it gets
crazier
chapter 33 verse number 37 he went to
his son and he did not find his
son home and he found the wife and the
wife she was wearing sexy clothes
see-through or something like that so
muhammad he flirt with her and he said
to her
praise be to allah the one who made my
heart match maker to you
flip for you now do you think
and muhammad is that you know he is the
father of
zaid by adoption you know
uh okay if imagine if you have
your father come to your house and then
your wife
when you come back home she says to you
your father he was here
and he flirt with me he says to me my
heart
is beating for you what you will do okay
okay
you know ah that's that's not that's not
good
this is a prophet
at this point cp is supposed to say
uh no it's not in the quran but
check out what he says instead yeah this
is the quran
after his guest buys into what he has to
say
he covers his tracks so that he wouldn't
get caught out and the details about
what happened
exactly what he said it's in the hadith
aha the details
by details he's referring to oh i don't
know pretty much
everything he said of course it goes
without saying that even according to
hadith standards the material that cp
brought doesn't even check out
and we're not even talking about how he
embellishes the reports with his
imagination
but that's how cp does cp and that's the
game
that he likes to play
i think that's all i have to say i mean
i feel sorry for this guy
and cp i freaking feel sorry for you
assalam alaikum guys
let's start this little show let me show
you what
after he said he says
anyone who take a white rooster huh
there's no shaytan and no magic will get
close to him do you agree with him in
the jersey
to give you guys a brief background a
brother named nightmare is debating cp
in regards to a hadith
the brother weakens it by quoting in new
jersey
cp then goes off on a tangent quoting
reports mentioned by mundosi
in order to hurt ibn jazi's credibility
that's his opinion well in his scholar
he is caught in a hadith this is a
hadith
no okay okay before i show you
do you agree with him or not
no i don't like him no you don't agree
with him so why you are calling me a
jersey then
what do you mean is the next space they
had it is forced
what what no okay but okay when he is
quoting those funny hadith they are not
forged
but now it's up to you you are the one
who decide which one you accept which
one you don't you don't accept
obviously it's not a josie you said he's
a scholar a second ago
you said he is a qualified for sure he's
a scholar like he said
okay hold on hold on okay
okay first of all i'd like to point out
how
bad cp's arabic is the text
says
okay it doesn't say in
allah the text would mean
allah has a rooster and cp
is reading it as allah is a rooster
with bad grammar as well but let's just
carry on
you
the book is called which is a book of
fabrications
collects these fabricated reports and
points out their weaknesses
so that readers know that the reports
are false
ibn jose then quotes the names of
several scholars that have weakened the
narrator of this hadith in order to
expose him
this is the scholar this is the scholar
you quote for me
is he a scholar or not
he's a scholar okay so now why he is
stupid
is he stupid now when we say this or you
accept it
why do you reject why you reject why you
reject who are you you are the one who
said he is a scar and the hadith
you just said if he isn't and he will
not say
no no no hold on you said he will not
say such a thing
any less unless it's true
and this guy's ig egypt okay carry on cp
let's see what else you got
and let me show you in the screen
oh
regretting machine his name right
suddenly
yes yes yes look guys look at this
okay look look at this look at this look
at this
read with me let us look at you before
carrying on i'd like to point out that
cp isn't even quoting ibn jose here
this should be obvious because of the
first words in the sentence
in el makaslad this is referring to
al-sahawi's
makaslid and sahawi came 300 years after
benjazi
cp there are two possibilities here
you either purposefully lie to your
audience like you did a couple of
minutes ago
or you are so ignorant that you don't
realize that you are quoting something
that came centuries after
beljozzi and to be fair i believe it's
the latter
cp is quoting
by muhammad and he assumed that this
source
was by ibn josi since the two books have
similar names
this should have been clear to an expert
like
cp since the page quotes other scholars
that
came centuries after ibn jazi as well
like ibn hajjar and esiyoti
looks like cp isn't as knowledgeable
as much as he thinks he is let us laugh
at you at your scholar you call
me supposedly to call me liar but let me
show you your scholar is a stupid idiot
look at this
what do you say of that
you are saying that to an arab guy i am
an arab this is my first language
this is the language i grow up as a man
reading it i have it
i'd like to end the video with this
deception
notice the word at the end here
we've already established that this
isn't even ibn jose's book even though
cp thinks it is but what is sadder is
that he is quoting a hadith that the
author condemns as a fabrication
look at this word in other words
fabrication i'd like to end this video
with an observation
i have not seen a christian apologist
lie as much as cp does
and this reflects badly on christianity
since he has become a symbol for
christians that engage with muslims
and polemics cp if you have the truth on
your side
then you do not need to lie during the
past
year i've watched tens of hours of
anti-islamic content
by atheists and none of them
come close to you when it comes to the
sheer quantity
of lies take care habibi
i'll see you in the next one
the rooster when he like
let's begin and see here see the
hypocrisy
how ahead in that verse only in the
whole quran
suddenly became one when the whole quran
translated the world ahead as any one
or one off you see that hypocrisy
how the word suddenly changed i had
always mean one off
you know one of one of many one of two
one of three
one of four doesn't matter he is one of
others so
when allah he says allah is ahad
well that's that's a problem and that's
a mistake
unless he is saying allah is ahad
the god who was around the kaaba there
was one of the idols
who was around the kaaba whose name is
ahad
an idol called ahad do you know what
this reminds me of
and the source cited is the author's
ass
he said
today we're going to be going through
one of the craziest
examples of uh christian prince's lies
and
manipulation um he lies about i think
three times in this video we're going to
go through them together inshaallah
basically he's arguing
that um the first chapter of the quran
speaks about farting yes i kid you not
this is how low uh this person is
let's let's uh check out the the first
clip
yes so so why you must
and you will see he is reciting it with
which mean farting
and naturally there are no examples um
that christian prince can't bring of
that ever happening
there are no sheikhs who recite
el-fatiha with the word now yes
al-burat means farting but
what muslims recite is
or and this is what actually
this is what christian prince intends
and will soon see
azeroth
and yes christian prince does know the
difference between
these are two completely different words
again christian prince
knows the difference el zarat is a
different way of saying
al-sarat and it's the
pronunciation of the tribe of kais right
benikez
and el burat just means farting
but let's just carry on see what what
this guy is going to come up with
and then he says and then he says
and then he says
and of course again as we can see here
christian prince is reading a line
that clearly uses the word zirat and
he's reading it as
arguing that advaita speaks about
farting
what the hell is this what the hell is
going on
here we go it says
what's wrong with
you said farting is this you who said to
me is it you who said to me a second ago
isn't it you as abdul isn't it you a
second ago
here's the thing you are doing too much
is it you who say it
isn't you who said to me what listen
forest isn't you who said to me a second
ago
i asked you what do i mean you said to
me 14
yes okay is it in front of you on the
screen says is it in front of you in the
screen saying your scholars singing that
it is
don't tell me click it you can click it
yourself this is the name of the book
now this is one of the really
interesting uh
parts in this discussion the person
that's
discussing with cp asks him to click on
the link
and cp refuses to click on the link so
why does he refuse to click on the link
well
we're about to find out all right guys
so here i'm going to demonstrate that
there's definitely something
odd going on i'm going to type in
um
and the only link that comes up is this
all right
the only link on the internet it's
cp's result and this is what he was
quoting
clicking on the link and what does it
say
this is why he didn't want to click on
it okay when you click on the link it
says
the plural for silat okay
um and and this makes perfect sense
because if you read here it says
like excuse me
like meaning
is like kitab and kutub and when it said
that makes no sense it doesn't really
fit in here it doesn't fit in with the
rest of the text
so that's a clear evidence that there's
some manipulation going on
but let's move over here to the search
feature and i'm going to type in
vorat or elvorat meaning farting
and check this out it says this this is
the same exact quote but it says
all right now check this out no preview
available for this page why is there no
preview for this page
i was just on the same page all right
one more time let's go back all right
where you at page 231 previews right
here
when you type in right
you get this so you get it you get the
same stuff but no preview available for
this page
so there's something fishy going on here
there seems to be some manipulation
and christian prince i think you owe us
an explanation
why didn't you want to click on the page
and why is this preview page unavailable
and why in the actual page
does it say
why allah he said the quran
why allah sent the quran
all right so let's quickly recap what's
going on in this video
christian prince argues that muslims
read this verse
as
meaning guide us to the straight
path of farting okay
one he says muslims recite this
scholars recite this ability recites
this
okay that's the first lie the second lie
is that he says that allah
revealed this as one of the
recitations and thirdly
he shows
a google result but will not click on a
link
deceiving the person that he's speaking
to deceiving the muslim
and the conversation and he knows very
well
if he clicks on the link he's going to
be exposed
so there are at least three lies by
christian prince here
the fourth possibility the the fourth
lie
and i'm not sure if this is from him or
from someone else
but there clearly appears to be a
manipulation on the website
um now that's
really low wow
anyone with a shred of dignity would not
use
such a silly and low argument i mean
the context of often
in itself refutes this absurd
understanding what the hell does
farting have to do with any of this how
low
can you get how low
and and again this
guy is the teacher of
david wood and sam shamoon and the
christian apologists
so and yes for the record i want you to
download this
i am confessing so muhammad hijab
doesn't need to guess
christian prince is my teacher and he's
the teacher of all the christians who
debate muslims
i am here i am here guys how many hours
today i stayed with you
how many hours six hours in the morning
or five and now oh god knows how many
hours did i ask you for money
he said dude you know
are you guys doing good are you guys
buckled up are you guys ready
for another episode on crazy uncle
prince
and his very horrible english grammar
coupled up
with a bunch of lies let's get into it
or
five and now god knows how many hours
did i ask you for money why muhammad is
a prophet of god i'm not a prophet
i'm just a normal human being i'm no one
i'm a no one i'm not just a human being
well if you're no one maybe we shouldn't
listen to you
why muhammad don't tell
that the prophet of god why allah he
care
if he want to meet somebody in a private
he have to be paid
when he want to meet someone in the
private he have to be paid
who is the one who is the who is the who
paid the prophet salallahu my friend
your prophet he do not need to be paid
if he is coming from god because god
will provide him
yes you do not need you do not no no you
do not need to make it an obligation for
everybody when i meet him in a private
to pay him read with me or who you
believe when you consult with the
messenger on private sen spend something
that is correct he's asking he's asking
now among the definitions of what it
means to be a liar
is to be a person that purposefully
covers up information pertaining to
truth
in order to deceive another person or
more people as you heard and so
he does not read the verse fully he
reads quote unquote
all you who believe when you consult the
messenger in private spend something
instead of continuing with the verse by
reading spend something in charity
before your private consultation
he stops at the words spend something
because he knows subconsciously
that if he reads the rest that he's
going to be refuted
as a side note he does not read the
verse fully for the rest of the
30 minute video of him screeching into
the microphone
and this is precisely what cp does here
he doesn't quote the verse fully
because it refutes him in essence he's
trying to make it seem as if allah
ordered people to give money to the
prophets of islam
when they wish to talk to him but this
is simply not the case as the verse is
talking about sadaqah
charity and saraka cannot be given to
the prophet sallam or his family
and the proof for this is the hadith of
abu hura in sahih al-bukhari
where it says that al-hasan ibn ali took
a date from the dates given in charity
and put it in his mouth
the prophet sallallahu alaihi said expel
it from your mouth
don't you know that we do not eat a
thing which is given
in charity in the arabic
so the word uses the same word is used
in the quran so mr
christian
you have been thoroughly refuted let's
continue
in advance my friend no no you see
anyone
anyone can talk to me anyone can talk to
me people they talk to me i have i
answer hundreds of emails
i make thousands of videos i never ask
anyone to pay me a penny i am not a
prophet
your prophet should be have a better
ethic than me why he make a condition
why why jesus why jesus listen listen
why
why jesus did not say you see my voice
is not good
why jesus did not say okay pay me before
you see me
the prophet saws why moses did not do
the same can you let me ask you the
question just so you can have a dialogue
the prophet salallahu he said he was
told to tell
the his people i do not ask you for
anything for any
again i'm not asking you for any payment
what are you asking me you're asking
he's asking
okay saying did allah
say the fifth of everybody to the
prophet yes or no
that is correct but did the prophets
take anything from it he took it for
sure he took it he will go the muslims
are fighting over an underwear don't you
see don't you eat with me
the muslims the muslims
is that a true story or not that the
muslims are fighting over the booty
accusing your prophet that he took an
underwear
yeah you are being very very uh
dishonest yeah because my friend the
proof in front of you
the proof in the front of you and the
screen the proof
the proof i don't care if you are in
youtube if you are in the moon you keep
saying to me dishonest i'm showing the
proof and the reference this is chapter
1 verse number 161
the muslims accuse the prophet that he
stole a bikini
so why you say to me you are being
dishonest so here
uncle prince says that the prophet
salallahu underwear or a bikini
this is simply something cp pulled out
of the place where the sun doesn't shine
because it is blatantly clear to anyone
reading that what is in question is a
red velvet cloth
in arabic this doesn't mean underwear
what the hell
on top of this cp claims that the
sahabah accused the prophet sallallahu
alaihi saw being fraudulent
but this is not the case as the text
says when some red velvet cloth went
missing on the day of brother
and some people began to say perhaps the
prophet took it
the following was revealed it is not for
a prophet to be fraudulent and yahuwah
or a variant reading it has the passive
and meaning to attribute rule or fraud
to him to the prophet saw
so basically what happened is the
sahabah had this feeling of the prophet
of taking something this doesn't mean
they accuse him of being fraudulent
but allah to emphasize how this is
impossible to even think that the
prophet saws took something let alone
for him to be
fraudulent is something that does not
benefit his honor or his character
so the verses were revealed also notice
how it says
some people meaning not all of the
sahaba and how it says also
perhaps the prophet sallallahu islam
took it they're just assuming they're
not accusing anyone of anything
the house of his own son when that when
the sun is not there and he flirt with
the wife
the prophet saws the highest moral
character what what highest
if your father be honest if your father
entered your house and you flirt with
your wife
is he a highest person or you just come
back this is inconceivable of the
prophet
what inconceivable what kind of a
prophet answer me why he did that and
explain to me why he did that why he
flirt with the married women
i just want to i want to just answer me
no answer me why he flirt with
give me a give me a logical explanation
he is a high ethic he is the best of
mankind
he is the best of people but he enter a
house of the husband
which is his son and he flirt with the
wife and he said to her lord with the
lord loud voice
my heart is a flipping for you praise be
to allah my heart is beating for you i
want you
what kind of man you say that what kind
of a man
okay here we go finally cp makes the
claim that the prophet salallahu flirted
with zainab
the biggest proof against him is the
very hadith that he is going to discuss
or rather screech about with a muslim
for 20 minutes straight
of course none of the hadiths or ayat
mentioned talk about the prophet
sallallahu alaihi islam saying to zainab
that his heart beats for her
but what can you expect that's just one
of crazy uncle prince's games with the
muslims
the hadiths and ayahs on the screen
basically talk about two things
the first few hadiths speak about how
one of the ayats that were revealed in
regards to this were the toughest on the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
now al-hasan and aisha radhiallahuma
both said that had it even been possible
that the prophet sallallahu islam would
hide anything of the revelation
it would have been this ayah as it was
too hard on his heart
the second part basically talks about
how zaid could not approach zainab
intimately
and for this reason he decided to
divorce her he told the prophet
sallallahu alaihi
about this decision
which means i want to divorce her so the
prophet saw allah
keep your wife and fear god so basically
cp like many other critics
want us to believe in the absurd claim
that the prophet salallahu sallam
at one point commands people to give him
whatever he wants demands to have
multiple wives to please himself
and then at another place he tells a man
to keep his wife even though he's
indirectly being offered
to divorce her i mean this is an absurd
claim as the prophet's sallallahu alaihi
islam character
is continuous what is even more
astonishing is how cp does not read the
verse fully where allah says
in english this means while you're
concealed within yourself that which
allies to disclose
and you fear the people while allah has
more right that you fear him
and as you can see on the screen the
verse goes on to explain
the reason for why the prophet
sallallahu alaihi married her so how
come
cp when the quran gives us detail to how
the prophet saws
did not disclose anything that he felt
about the case was zainab
you ignore this crucial fact it is not
possible that the prophet sallallahu
conceals what he feels about zainab and
at the same time flirts with her
otherwise the sahaba wouldn't emphasize
how hard it was for the prophet
sallallahu islam to have these ayat
revealed
as these ayat disclosed what was in the
heart of the prophet
sallallahu islam that the people did not
know but
i mean at the end of the day who cares
for wasteman cp
it's all about screeching in the
microphone and calling us
a
and we have quite the show for you
i'm excited let's get in yeah let's do
this
so this is like a one minute long video
and in this clip
christian prince lies quite a bunch of
times
and i'm i'm just gonna enjoy watching
abdullah's reaction to this
he's got no idea what he's um
getting himself into is about it you can
see and you can watch
where house was accused by the muslim
that he is a fraud
and here we go we don't do what the
muslims do they make us
they make a statement without proving
what they say this is your islamic
website this is your muslim books
they are witnessing even if new jersey
as you see in the screen
they're speaking about half subnew
suriman who is you
you muslims all of you you recite his
quran you don't have other quran to
recite
all right that that's the first one okay
so i'd like to point out that he he's
arguing that the only qra is
for for some reason i think was an
intention is to let's attack halfs
and if we attack halfs there are no
other recitations and
islam is false i'm i'm assuming that's
what he's going for
but that's the first lie
and he they say that this man he is a
fabricator and who is the one who saying
that let me count for you the names of
the scholars
give me josie all right all right is it
josie accusing house of lying abdullah
who is he's he's he's saying that
a bill josie yeah and el bazaz accused
him of lying
is that what he's doing yes
okay this should be good
albuquerque
[Laughter]
this is what we're dealing with this is
what we're dealing with
so so please share your thoughts what's
what's crazy here
who who are the people that are accusing
um hufflepuff lying so far
according to this fight this guy well uh
alphazazz
so far what's the problem with with all
of those
the problem is that
josie's not neither is it
is house yes reference to house
um and so is abu dawud that's also a
reference to house
yeah none of them have even called him a
liar
yeah and the the only person he's gone
thus right so far is
uh al buhari and buhari also did not
call him a liar but exactly
exactly saying they ignored them or they
left and doesn't mean that bukhari
considers him a liar
i'd like to point out that benjazi
simply is collecting what others have
said
benjamin hasn't called him a liar so the
we we got one lie
benjazi al-bazaz that's the second um
that's the third and um
that's four okay we got four so far
let's see how many we can get
oh the fifth one is happens so we're not
even
we're like you know 30 seconds in and
this guy's got five flies so far let's
carry on
ahmad imam ahmad muslim
when he say they said about him that he
is kadhab he is a liar that's literally
not what they said about him
who said that
did you get that did you get that
he said he's insane
he made him a person yes yes
right so it changed mara
one time into a person's name
murrah and made it the opinion of murrah
that's which is the event
um and he said that they'll call him a
liar and literally that's not what they
called it like he underlined all their
names
and what they said after and it's
literally this is
which is literally not the same thing um
what i thought what i find really
interesting is
um it's he's acting as if he knows
that's what i find so special it's like
you guys don't know
let's carry on say even al-bukhari he
said they left his hadith which means
his hadith is
ignored totally ignored for he's a liar
same as assadi
same as abdul rahman ibn yusuf nuharaj
he said
hadith which means he is a liar
fabricator he fabricate hadith
that's more that's the first one he's
gone right isn't it
yeah yeah so finally
yes and what's funny that he already
quoted in bukhari as calling him a liar
then quotes him down here as saying
right right
let's carry on even they accuse him that
he steals books and he claimed that he
is the one who wrote it
even at the rakhani he said that even if
he says that
even in
what we have in front of us here is an
image of
those that have criticized house at the
same time you have people who praised
house
and these are not on this screen
now anyone that is going to argue that
house is a liar is stuck
because that's something that they
cannot prove practically
you see anything that house has recited
has been corroborated by someone else
they're pretty much stuck with this one
in general different fields require
different um
you know abilities for a person and
memorization of the quran and a person's
expertise in it says nothing of their
abilities in hadith
just like a person's expertise in phila
says nothing of their abilities in
hadith
as does their expertise in hadeem says
nothing of their abilities in phil
the person that was the harshest against
house um
that's like that's someone that we um
take
in from is yahya and yet yahya
appraises hafsa's recitation any any
last thoughts bro any uh
advice you want to give to christian
prince any advice you want to share
because that's it by the way that's it
we okay there was like eight lies in
here in like uh
in a minute and a half yeah i mean it's
it's very humorous
um i actually i mean
i hope he continues doing what he does
it's hilarious
um uh you know
sometimes a person you know they just
need to speak in order for you to
realize while they're an idiot
it was a pleasure having you on board we
need to do this more often
as always happy bee take care of
yourself guys follow abdullah martez you
can find
his twitter handle down there below in
the
bottom right corner of the screen take
cares of yourselves
american laboratory another day
another video about christian prince
and his lies let's let's check it out
let's see what he has to say
uh this is the muslim translation the
hour the judgment
is night which means very very close and
the moon
is a cliff ascender so muhammad
reporting to us what that judgment day
is already started here we go the moon
split
muhammad he saw the eclipse he claimed
that this is judgment day something a
big happened at that time
which is big eclipse and muhammad he
think that that's this is a sign of
judgment day
oh yeah yeah that makes a lot of sense i
mean that's how i feel
um every time i see an eclipse
i i i assume that it's just the moon
splitting
okay so this is the first light by cp
absolutely no sense
he's interpreting a verse
in a way that conflicts with a text and
he's just lying to the caller that's
calling him up now muhammad muhammad he
claimed here to be a prophet
and he prophesy about judgment day is in
the corner and that was 1400 years and
he claimed
that this is the start of judgment day
is not just coming
it started because the moon spread
okay so the second thing here is we can
see
um cp is actually claiming that the
prophet peace be upon him said that
judgment day
started this never happened rasulullah
never said
the judgment day started there are
multiple verses
in the quran that clearly indicate that
rasulullah doesn't know
when judgment day is going to start so
this is
another lie by cp
so why didn't why did why didn't those
believers leave their religion
what they are leaving they are leaving
if you give them a chance to leave
there's many people who find out the
truth but if you live in the middle east
they will kill you if you live islam
but there wasn't that many followers my
friend yeah
did you hear about the war of upper
state okay
so this is the third and final lie
that i call this video there are
probably more but i mean this is what i
call this is what i noticed
um as we can see the caller subhanallah
actually asks a good question and
he simply says if this was
if judgment day didn't occur at the time
and
the peace be upon him was exposed for
this false prophecy
um and remember keep in mind that
apparently according to cp thought that
the moon split when reality was an
eclipse i mean this enough would have
been
this this itself would have been enough
to completely destroy the prophet saws
claim
of being a prophet if he was a pop if he
was a false prophet
you should have had mass apostasy cp
claims well the muslims
excuse me excuse me um anyone who
disregarded islam
at that time would have been killed and
cp
knows he knows very well
that this occurred in mecca when the
muslims were a minority
and were being targeted by the
oppressive
pagans and no the easiest thing in the
world would be to leave your religion
you won't be
killed for leaving islam there was no
apostasy law at the time either so
la sivie that's your third lie
i'm not lying to you my friend people
are watching me by hundreds and if i'm
lying people will make fun of me
as we're doing another
rapid fire round with a bunch of cp's
lies in succession
check this out and see how many lies
you can find okay the name of is is the
name of your prophet
or muhammad
ahmed his name is ahmad
muhammad saw he have two names those are
like religions of his name
so obviously that is not a name muhammad
he changed his name
first lie muhammad peace be upon him
never
change his name because you cannot have
all those names either
you can have okay so you can have david
dave right so those
are all all those names all those names
mean what mean the praised one so
muhammad he claimed to be god
second lie he never claimed to be god
call himself the praised one making
people worship in him
third lie he never made anyone worship
him
this is especially absurd if you feel
that calling yourself muhammad means
that you
should be worshipped muhammad is one of
the most common names around
the prophet peace be upon him also had
contemporaries
with the same name the real name
the real name
fourth lie his claim that the prophet's
real name peace be upon him was gotham
where do you get that you can go and
search for go right now sir
the prophet muhammad his real name is
qatam in arabic and you will find tons
of articles written by muslims muslims
not us
which are this the muslims even in in
uh in the book of ibrahimovic says that
a fifth lie
there's no such thing in ibn kether's
works
when when the the uncle of muhammad
muhammad he used to have an anker
he passed away his name is gotham sixth
lie
his uncle's name is not
kathem his name
was o tham po them
is one who is generous with them is also
the name of the prophet's cousin peace
be upon him
now i do not believe that cp just made a
simple mistake here i do
believe he intentionally distorted the
name due to his hatred for the prophet
peace be upon him he passed away
so the arab they used to do what when
when the new baby is born
is a male they give the new male the
name of the number of
of the name of the member who passed
away to keep his name exist
so qatar muhammad was the first born
after that guy
seventh lie there is no proof that the
prophet peace be upon him
was the first person born in the family
after
them and that's pretty much it did i
miss anything
do let me know in the comments below
otherwise take cares of yourselves
what's up welcome to love what i can't
do hey listen abdul i'm not a kid
i am a scholar you are a donkey
welcome to another video about cp
and his lies in today's video we're
going to be talking about
um decency around the kaaba
and the pagan practice of people
worshiping while being nude
arab before islam they used to go or
walk naked around the kaaba
do you know that or no uh
no not naked or something i just knew
that they had
so many idols around they used to go
naked because this is
a naked religion this is a sexual
religion and islam is nothing but a
continue of this sexual religion first
lie
it's very important to keep in mind how
unfair christian prince is to islam
he'll turn even the most positive thing
in islam into a negative one
and this is just a perfect example of
that notice how he says that islam
is a continuum of this sexual religion
how is this uh continue
well islamic law dictates that one needs
to wear clothes around the cap
but let's just see what christian prince
has to say
if we go in the hadith in the hadith
the hadith says confirm that even
after muhammad took over makkah still
the people used to go around the cabinet
look hisham narrated in the authority of
his father blah blah blah
blah it's okay he says in the uh the
arab in the exception of the homs
who we're in uh quraysh and their
descendant
they go around the kaaba naked do you
see it
so this is the second lie cp is quoting
a hadith that is referring to
the practices before islam there is no
indication from this report
that this is referring to makkah after
it
became under islamic rule in the year 8
after hijra so you go around the kaaba
today
and you still naked nothing changed
muhammad all what he did he made you
wear a sheet
this is the third lie guys i'm going to
flash an image of the sexual religion
that christian prince is referring to if
you have any children in the room
i'd advise you to make them look away
three two one
oh my god i hope youtube doesn't take
this
video down due to nudity
anyways let's get serious cp's about to
provide the reason as to why the prophet
peace be upon him
forbade nudity around the kaaba
you will see that he like a woman and he
was
jealous that everybody looking at her
bum and her vagina
and her breast he wanted to marry her
or to have her to be his girlfriend
so because of that women after that
after the women she she she go around
the kaaba and she was singing
the same song which they used to sing
for for centuries
and this is the fourth and final lie the
prophet peace be upon him
enforced allah ending nudity around the
kaaba
while he was in medina in the year nine
after hijrah
this was not triggered because of a
woman that he saw in makkah
because again he was in medina but
regardless of all that let's assume that
everything that cp said is true
guess what by enforcing this law
islam has put an end to this deviance
by ending nudity around the kappa
so christian prince how is this exactly
a continue of this sexual religion
no no no that's not true man isn't it
assalam alaikum everyone this is a
hilarious video where cp
gets busted by a color a brief
background before starting
the topic of discussion is what occurred
between the christians of najiran
and the prophet peace be upon him the
caller who refers to himself as
nightmare says that there was a debate
between the two parties cp on the other
hand
christian prince holds the view that
there was no debate
but the prophet peace be upon him
completely avoided it
and yeah let's just check out the video
canada
they made an appointment with him
tomorrow let us debate tomorrow so
muhammad he says to them when they
arrive
here we go the debate time is set up
when they arrive
he said to them
i have a news from the from the
from the uh uh which means from the
angel about the people of alinadron the
christians who came from there
that i should invite him to do mulana
which means the cursing party
what is the debate okay did you finish
yeah go ahead okay oh man you have no
clue what you are talking
about
they were debating the prophet my friend
is don't call me again
let your let your parents call me you
stupid it's in front of you
oh offer it why don't you debate cp
why if you're a man then you'll call him
on his show
are you people uh normal
are you people nuts this is what happens
when he gets destroyed on his own show
all right so let's just carry on and
hear his ridiculous interpretation of
the text
they never met him they speak against
him there's nothing in the text
that says that they never met him the
text clearly says
meaning that they argued or debated
about jesus
this is the first lie
this is before they met him they're
talking about isa they said to him you
are wrong they didn't they never met him
the second lie
is that he says that this means that
yuja diluen means they spoke against him
and this is false
isn't a term used for some sort of
one-way condemnation
it refers to a discussion so he set up a
debate time when they arrive
he said to them that the angel said to
me ask them to invite their women and
their children and my women and my
children let us curse the one who is
invoking
invoke allah to curse the one is lying
he does not debate him you idiot
what can you use for it's in front of
your eyes
when i'm going to find a muslim he knows
how to read arabic
they are not debating his oppressed they
are they are saying he is not telling
the truth
they never debated him yet
this is before they came they are saying
muhammad is a liar
third lie cp uses the term yuja lunafi
to express that the prophet peace be
upon him wasn't present
now this is false again fi which means
about
him means that they were arguing with
the prophet peace be upon him
about him him being jesus there are two
possible scenarios the first is that
christians argued with the prophet peace
be upon him while they were in negelan
which was three weeks away from medina
now unless they took the 7 30 flight i
don't see how they could have made it
on time tomorrow as the report
says the other scenario is that they
were already in medina
and had a discussion as the report
plainly says
then they were invited to invoke the
curse of allah on the next day so yeah
that's pretty much it
i don't really have much more to say
you're stupid
i've decided to change things up a bit
in this video
um i'm going to be reacting to one of
chris and prince's videos
um i'm not going to be focusing much on
the jokes it's not going to be really
funny it's an inter it's a it's an
important
um this is an important video and
i was quite disturbed uh when i saw this
one
um because as you'll see
cp lies to someone and tricks them
out of islam
let's watch this together
which one is the true one the one we
should do as a human
but always always deceiving things is
more attractive and here you will notice
with me
i don't know if you saw the height i was
showing you that real prophet he said
that when you go to heaven allah will
make your penis will never sleep
isn't it the same as the guy who said to
me that
go to the bar which is the devil
over going to help somebody who need
help
do you see a heath in the front of you
on screen my friend
i don't but i'm following you okay it
says muhammad taking an oath saying
there's no one whom allah admit to
paradise but allah will marry him to 72
wives two from the huri's and 70 from
the inheritance from the people
of hell all of whom have desirable
front passages which mean muhammad allah
even describing for us
that those women are especially imported
from hell
do you know what does that mean why does
like what do you think
about why those women allah will take
them from hell why they are coming from
hell
because david because they're the
dirtiest because they are what
the there is because they are hookers
they are
they are expert in sex so allah will
choose for you from the
earth from the warehouse of hell the
best of the hookers who
are very good in all the skills of sex
we don't ever give details
and now he described to us that they are
very beautiful to the point
you will be crazy when you see their
boobs and their vagina
excuse my language okay so first of all
the verse excuse me the hadith doesn't
say that
he doesn't say that you're going to go
crazy um
while looking at their parts
and more importantly when we actually go
to the hadith which i have
right here as we can see the
text in arabic is quite clear that this
has nothing to do
with them being with with the female
with females that are being being
brought into heaven
this has nothing to do with them being
good in sex or anything like that
rather the arabic
specifically states that these
will be good women because the example
that is brought
is the wife of the pharaoh who was of
course
well praised as we know for being a good
person
um cp is aware of this he can see the
arabic he reads the arabic
and yet he's referring to these
women as hookers in order to make
the image of heaven and islam to look
as twisted as possible
okay um let's move on
what kind of a prophet he said that and
look what he continues saying
and he will have he will have a male
member
which will never became a flossett i.e
soft limp okay i got you
this is god okay so
let's check out the hadith again notice
in the bottom left side of the screen it
says
this is alive this is a weak hadith
all right let's go back to christian
prince
you cannot see the word life you cannot
see
that this is a rejected hadith he has
purposefully
hid that away from the caller he doesn't
want the caller to be aware
that he's quoting a weak hadith now
i know christian prince doesn't care
about that he will quote
hadith and he says that there is no
issue with coding weak hadiths
but then why are you showing why are you
showing the caller
that the hadith has been great as weak
so this is the third lie he's claiming
that this is from rasulullah
he knows it's not he can see that the
hadith is weak
and yet he's hiding it away
and i'm just going to play this
um i want you to see what this leads to
all right
how does how this can be a prophet of
god speaking to me about heaven of god
saying to me
don't worry be happy allah will provide
you with penis will never go sleep
because it's made from concrete
and the women allah will go to the
warehouse of hell and he will import for
you
the best women in sex from hellfire
[Music]
shameless so my friend adam what are you
waiting for
denounce this garbage man this is this
is not for you you are smarter than this
you are honorable man you cannot be a
person
yeah subhan allah muslims have denounced
this
muslims have denounced this by calling
this a hadith he's holding this
against islam in order to convert a
muslim
to christianity
a disgusting individual belong to this
where do i belong do you want to belong
to muhammad
after what you heard
do you want to belong to this
do you want really to believe in someone
teaching you this
be honest
[Music]
now
yeah so based on what you said no
well you know
hello so my friend say it say muhammad
can't be a prophet they announced
muhammad right now
they know the devil my friend
i'm waiting so
you want me to denounce the devil
muhammad obviously this is the devil my
friend say muhammad can't be a prophet
of god i am out of this
okay
so what is it what do you think what you
should say
i think
tough words to be honest with you i know
you are a band of courage and you can
say it my friend denounce him
your honor is in the stake your honor do
you accept this this is
this is about honor a person
no no you see you you did not choose
where you are coming from nothing wrong
with that you see
i me and you we did not choose but when
we grow
yeah i can't say to you i can't speak to
you them words and then
then go to my community and pretend like
i never said
well say it you know you want to go to
the community you say to them you want
to be hypocrite
i don't want to be here
you are worried about your community but
you are not worried
about your honor you wanna you wanna you
wanna fool yourself says
so you are saying to me okay he's
talking about honor
he's talking about honor he's talking
about hypocrisy and this is a person
calling to truth
while lying to the person that he's
talking to
and calling it's crazy
i agree with you muhammad is a false
prophet obviously this is devilish
cannot be from god
but because i have a community and i
have to make them happy with me i'm not
going to say that
yeah but that means i accept with my
respect to you to be hypocrite
hypocrisy hypocrisy is to say to people
not what i believe
is not what they think is right for them
correct yeah so now you believe that
muhammad is not a prophet but yet you
want to say to them muhammad is a
prophet just because
you don't want to make them make them
sad but but that you know you will
respect respect yourself
it's up to you you know so denounce
muhammad say
be a man and i'm sure you are the man
denounce him and say muhammad can't be a
prophet there is no way i'm going to
follow such a man
okay uh muhammad cannot how do you prove
him
i mean to that wonderful i'm so happy
for you
my friend muhammad i'm sorry and you
know i'm happy for you that you make a
decision
now as long you made a decision that
muhammad is a false man
which is a wonderful thing to do i want
you
to step back and think about
what is next what is the best to follow
maybe nothing is best to follow maybe
stay an atheist or maybe the messiah
who has no name like him and no name
better than him
he never say false he never speak sin he
never do sin
the one who is above the heaven and the
earth the one who did miracles which is
amazing
the one who said something nobody can
say love your enemy
so i am inviting you right now to accept
my lord the messiah to be your savior
i'm not forcing you to accept it because
in christianity
you have to be reborn again there's
nothing is called
born of a christian family we don't
believe in that you have to be reborn
again with the christ which mean
you have to make a decision of your own
that i am adam who was a muslim
and now i denounce the devil i want to
accept the messiah as my savior
as my personal god that is a personal
choice you make
not something you inherit
we are not muslim we don't believe in
that so if you want to accept the
messiah i invite you right now i have
the honor
to present to you the best name
of the good god
which his name is amazing
his name is the messiah if you like to
accept him feel free to say
i accept
i accept amazing i mean i mean
hallelujah
hallelujah today my friend adam
and there you have it so this guy this
fellow the samskeen
um left islam
without knowing islam apparently didn't
really have much proof for islam
and this is what happens with a lot of
christian princes callers they call his
show and they don't even know when
they're muslims
and all it takes is a couple of
arguments
a couple of lies and statements
like why are you a muslim
denounce this a bit of pressure and
that's it for them
and notice what caused him to become a
christian was there any proof
that led him to christianity were there
any arguments no
it's just i invite you to accept
my lord and savior jesus christ and
that's it and these people they're
that um
fickle they're
just going with the flow and there you
go
and all it's going to take is someone to
challenge this guy's belief
it's just gonna take a three minute
conversation five minute conversation
and he's gonna switch to something else
and this is the danger guys
i i wrote a little tweet um earlier
today
saying something along the lines of
ask yourself why am i muslim
before someone asks you why are you a
muslim
if you don't have a good answer to your
question
then you're going to have a crisis when
you're asked
this question
that's all i have to say assalamualaikum
to love
hey i can't really believe that we're
already at 60 lies
for those of you who have stuck around
for this long
i salute you glad you find this stuff
entertaining
at the time of me working on this video
i find myself running out of steam
i wonder how many more of these i can
handle
how much more cp can i listen to
before i develop a tumor in my ear
the things i do for you guys
if we go in the quran you will find the
following muhammad in the beginning of
his life
he said this when in the beginning of
his uh let us say a prophethood
he claimed to be a prophet he said the
following
that those who are jews and those who
are a christian and those who
are sabian they have nothing to worry
about and they will go to heaven
first lie cp claims that this verse was
revealed in the beginning of the
prophethood
this is false and cp knows it he knows
very well that chapter 2 surah
al-baqarah was revealed in medina
at least 13 years after islam started
a very similar verse can also be found
in surat al-ma'dah
which was the last chapter to be
revealed in the quran
chapter 2 verse number
how we say that christianity is false
and then he
in his time he's a promising the
christians and the jews and the sabians
to go to heaven
is he's promising everyone heaven
absolutely and not only that he's
probably in the sabian who worships
stars
so you're making him seem as though he
was just trying to recruit
he was trying to make himself accepted
and for everybody like obama during the
election
like in america you know
when people they speak to atheists he
plays as an atheist when
when when the one who want to support
him as a gay he said i have no problem
with gay
when he speak to christians he said to
them i love the bible when he speak to
muslims he said to them the prophet
muhammad was amazing so
they have many colors they have many
many you know forms
because they are deceivers second lie
the prophet peace be upon him was not
trying to make himself acceptable at all
he openly told his own tribe that their
forefathers are going to hell
he openly told them that they would
follow if they didn't accept his message
which is why the muslims suffered the
tyranny of quraysh during the first 13
years of the message
with christians he denied the
crucifixion of jesus if his intention
was to win their hearts
there would be no reason to deny his
crucifixion
so no making himself acceptable
was in no way a priority if muhammad is
a decent man
muhammad is a decent prophet and he
believed in in what you just said that
the christians are corrupt
then how he promised the christians
this time muhammad in this time he's
talking to people who are around him not
people who
are passed away he said the christians
the jews and the soviets
all they are about but look what
happened when muhammad give up that the
jews will not accept him the christians
are not accepting him
then he starts focusing on killing the
jews
and the christian not the sabian the
third lie cp is very well aware that the
christians of najaran
openly rejected rasool allah and he
didn't lay a finger on them
the prophet peace be upon him never
killed anyone for simply rejecting him
the battles that occurred between the
prophet peace be upon him and the jews
have been discussed in other videos
on this channel if you care to look into
that
that's pretty much it for this one all
right boys
all of this done by the help of obama
and i'm going i'm going to give you
links to show you how muslims they lie
to you my friend hold on hold on okay no
problem
no problem no problem ibn kathir which
would you make it simple every cathedral
confirm
that shaitaan you throw in the mouth of
muhammad
satanic verses do you agree with that or
no
[Music]
at this point many of the skeletors here
may say mention
the story of alvaro and how many of
those who had
migrated to ethiopia came back when they
were they thought that the adulterers of
quraysh had become muslims
here he says but those reports all come
from a through
morsel chains about what about those who
came from ethiopia
because of this story so he is claiming
that ibn kasir confirmed the story of
al-kharanik
but he didn't confirm the story of
muslims returning back from ethiopia
because of this story
really are you serious please tell me
that you are joking
please where did ibn kasir even say that
ibn kasir clearly said that the story
itself which is known as al-kharmic
the story itself and the return of
muslims because of this story
all of this are from reports with more
such chains ibn kasir didn't even say
that only this part is morsel
ibn kasir clearly said that this story
which is known as alarmic is from
reports with unreliable
morsel chains and none of them are but
since he wants to play stupid games
he twisted the words of ibn kazir which
doesn't fit with his agenda
the story itself is known as ibn kasir
clearly says here is that the story of
is morsel and doesn't come from any
authentic chain
this is what indication clearly says
of revelation
and uh of them maybe regard as sahih
okay okay wait wait can you read this
part again
and of them maybe regard as sahih
okay and uh maybe okay
so as we can clearly see the text says i
don't think that any of them
may be regarded as but this joker
twisted and manipulated the text and
made it as end of them may be rewarded
as
while ibn kasir really says i don't
think that any of them may be rewarded
he did this distortion of the text
simply because he is a deceiver
he is twisting and manipulating the text
to fit with his agenda you do not know
how to read and you do not know what you
are talking about
yes sure sure of course we cannot deny
it if we go to alcor to be here we go
this is al-kortavi he confirmed the
story
he mentions in the tafsir of surah 22
so 52 life
narrated from yunus from she have a
zohori
from abbey rahman bin
said
he made a mistake and said their
intercession is hope
pagan idolaters whose in their heart was
a disease
met him greeted him and they were happy
he then said where this is from devil
then allah revealed 52 of
hajj now notice something whenever
he quotes the classification
authentication
what the authentication says now and has
he says again about this relation
what does he say he say this narration
is odd
monkey odd and disconnected
also said in the same page it is enough
that this narration
i.e story of allah was not mentioned by
anyone from the people of authenticity
and was not narrated with any reliable
connected chain of narration
yet this clown who calls himself
christian prince is saying that alcor
toby confirmed the story
so whom we should trust here should we
trust
or trust an unknown troll hiding behind
his screen
the choice is yours if we go to allah
you will see that allah he sent the
angel jabril
a day after this is not from allah which
means muhammad himself he did not even
notice
that this is not from god brother
yeah okay let's go to rosie
if we go to the interpretation of he
says
is not confirmed from the way of its
transmission is not confirmed from the
way of its transmission
then he spoke about generators of this
story are unreliable
the narrators of this story are
unreliable and also al-bukhari narrated
in his sahih
that the prophet alaihissalam recited
the surah of a nazim and proceeded with
him the muslims pagans
all mankind and yen without mentioning
the story of
nick i.e satanic versus story ends the
funny thing is that from the same page
of
sira rosie which he is showing razi
himself says
so by this ways we know that this story
is satanic verses
is fabrication so why he didn't read
this to his brainwashed followers
simply because he is deceiving them he
is taking advantage over their ignorance
why they lie to us and why they lie to
themselves
any muslim have the courage to call me
and prove me wrong
guys did i show all the reference which
is proven my point or i did not
why you jumped like a monkey why you
jumped like a monkey a second ago you
said to me if you go to wikipedia you
will find that jesus is dead
yes okay the quran says that jesus is
alive what are you are making fun of
allah
oh i told you i told you i'm not
religious it doesn't matter if you're
religious or not
so now do you swallow your tongue and
you apologize to allah that jesus is in
heaven or you still insist that jesus is
not in heaven
my friend this is not the question are
you willing to apologize from the
prophet muhammad that he is telling the
truth and jesus now in heaven or is
still you don't believe in muhammad in
the truth
are religious what religious means
do i do i believe in a religion you see
i i have no time for a stupid talk go
let your dad call me when i showed him
that the quran says that jesus
is in heaven now he don't want to talk
about it no more he watching the topic
and the other donkey who called me says
to you i got you busted
i got you busted jacob jacob is not
israel
if i show you now your prophet saying
that what you will do you will cry like
a baby
don't call me kid
i said to him no i said to him no jesus
your brother a muslim guy a muslim guy
he called me before you
he said that he said if you go to work
hold on hold on
let me talk your brother he called me
before you and he said
if he if he said he said to me as jesus
is alive i said yes he said well how
come if i go to work abidia
i find him dead i said well are you
saying that
the quran lie and then he hang up
because i showed him the quran saying
that allah he took him up to heaven and
then he hanged up and then he hung up
and then he hanged up
okay so you know what what it is it's
that he's so
used to lying that he just can't stop
he just he just can't stop he's tr i
mean
like this was 15 minutes ago
but he can't help himself oh
my god don't call me kid
all right guys this is going to be a
very short video inshallah
christian prince is talking about the
same old shubaha
that was brought up in the whole david
wood muhammad hijab debate about allah
praying to the prophet busy upon him
ridiculous ridiculous ridiculous
whatever all right christian prince what
you got
when allah he pray he pray to who there
is no answer
if allah is sending the blessing how the
angels and the
and the human they can do the same as
the act of allah it's impossible
if allah sent the blessing why he is
saying i injeed
you you see what happened in islam
muhammad he made himself the center of
the universe
the first lie is that cp is saying the
center of attention islam is the prophet
peace be upon him that's not true um
even in the quran we find musa being
mentioned more than the prophet peace be
upon him we find
isa being mentioned more than the
prophet peace be upon him
and obviously the center of attention in
islam
is allah this is a clear
lie by cp there's no other way around
this one
to the point he wants us to believe that
god
and the angels and everybody he is
praying
busy praying on one person his name is
muhammad
the second lie is that allah prays
to the prophet this has been covered
previously by muhammad hijab
here's just a little hadith i'd like to
share with you
do check it out no allah allah is not
worshipping al-abi alpha
okay he's not worshiping al-abiyah
everybody is praying on muhammad
you name it there's not even a single
person don't pray on muhammad
um and line number three cp says
that all people
prey upon the prophet peace be upon him
this is
false i don't know where he's getting
this from
not this is not an islamic ideology
everyone can simply see
that non-muslims don't prey upon the
prophet
this is this is some sort of funky
ideology that
cp has come up with and as a tribute to
islam
and i'll see you guys in the next one
my fellow geologists how are you guys
doing
oh my god i get it gets better every
time really
um so for this video i actually looked
at a suggestion
by a dear uh you know uh how do you
say it online friend of mine that i met
on twitter
sheikh dr so so
and he basically showed me this uh
thread he made in regards to a video by
cp
and i first of all want to thank him for
showing me this
i want to ask you guys to follow him on
twitter and also
i wish to make a video on this and
basically most of the stuff that you're
going to watch
is a contention on
cp's lies based upon doctors
heipzide's observations and some of my
own
stuff in there as well so let's get
right into it boys shall we
if a muslim says something to you why
right away you come to the conclusion
that must be true
actually the second the muslim he said
the word true
for me i add the word lie
okay perfect let's try this
cp is mentally stable true cp has hair
true cp has some intelligence
true this statement is takaya true
automatically why because my experience
with islam and muslims never ever ever
once told the truth my experience
never told the truth excuse me boy
pringles but
an experience is a natural phenomena
that does not speak
go back to school and learn some proper
english grammar
before you even attempt to express
yourself rainbow mountains
mentioned in the quran or in china
i mean did you even check it out and see
how silly it is
who is the silly you who sent me this or
the muslims will say that to you
so basically some person argues for a
scientific miracle in the quran saying
that the mountains in china have
different color
and that these mountains are mentioned
in the quran this is simply false it's
none of the tafseers mentioned this at
least to my own knowledge
and this is an obvious projection on the
text that is unnecessary
sure perhaps the colorful mountains in
china will remind us of the notion of
differently colored
mountains being mentioned in the quran
but the quran clearly is not talking
about
china the prophet sallam himself never
went to china
why in the world people who belong to
the true god they fabricate lies
if allah is a true god
that is a clear proof that muslims don't
belong to the true god
you have to be a person who belong to
the devil
to justify fabrication and lies
i guess we can then conclude based on
our current series
the cp is shaytan's little triggered
sheep
not sure why don't you see that allah
sends down
water from the cloud
that is a discovery by the way that is a
discovery
the quran does not make the claim of
this being a discovery
rather i recommend that you guys pause
the video and read dr
saeed's explanation on how we should
read ayat referring to natural phenomena
such as this
the the water is coming from the ocean
not from the cloud
allah he sent down the water from the
cloud let us
let it go and where exactly does the
water come from
before it enters the ocean yujah the
clouds the rain above them
i.e the oceans and the rivers that flow
into them
also what about the fact that rivers are
formed
literally in a way from clouds because
of the rain which comes down from them
and then forms springs this is worse
than ap's gust front theory
it's a continuous natural cycle this is
a formal fallacy wherein there lies a
false assumption
that the proposition water comes from
the clouds negates the emergence of
water from oceans and rivers
this is simply illogical because just
because i say that for example
water comes from a pipe this does not
mean that i'm negating
it coming from clouds in the form of
rain or other
forms of water sources now let us
continue
with annihilating this little potential
rapist boy
who asks muslim women for naked pictures
red
and various hoes and other
instantly black instantly
whatever the hell that means
the some hills are black because the the
the sand or the rocks in that area are
black
i mean this is what this have to do with
the china what does have to do with
with the with the rainbow and i mean
it's really stupid and silly
remember what he just said here because
it's going to expose them later in the
video
for sure this other hadith says that
allah created the black people from the
left shoulder of adam and he said let
them go to hell and he said
let me create and he hit the shoulder of
adam and he created the white people
from the right shoulder of adam and he
said let them go to heaven which means
black will go to hell and white will go
to heaven according to islam
but these verses have not the hadith on
black and white souls is actually
created weak because the narrator is
sulaiman evan otbah who
narrates his sololy and his unique
narrations are never
accepted for the reason being that he
would
narrate strange things and imam ibn
mahin among others consider him to be
weak
but even if the hadith wasn't weak you'd
have to be a complete idiot
to think that this refers to skin color
when what is being spoken about is
demonstrating the evil people and the
good people that will come from adam
alaihissalam
wherein the black color represents evil
and white color represents good
this has nothing to do with skin color
though it is a presupposition
upon the text
see you not that allah sent down the
water from the sky
and we produce there there with fruits
of various color and among
the mountains are jude white and red
of very uh varying colors
and others
[Music]
among them are judded white and red
of verifying colors means he created the
mountains like this
he's not talking about specific mountain
he claimed that all the mountains in the
world
they are created with many colors with
different
and here comes the main lie of cp in
this video
first of all the opposite is true the
men used in this ayah
is for taba'ed or parting in other words
it does not refer to all mountains it
says
minarjibad and for god's sake even the
english is clear it says and from among
the mountains not and the mountains so
when even kathir
uses the word the mountains he is
clearly not referring to all of them
pathways so the muslims even disagree
pathways guys
yes
[Music]
translation
praise be allah be to allah who created
out
of nothing this between between
two brackets not existing the quran the
heaven and the earth
actually the word fatter comes from fata
which means to originate something that
is
to bring about something without it
being present
prior to that so no cp
it's not an invalid interpolation in the
translation of the text
who made angels messengers with wings
two or three or four okay hold on
did muhammad guys say that he saw angel
jabri with 600 wings
any abdul how the quran says there's
angels have two
and four and six wings
and and eight wings let us say
and muhammad he says he saw the angel
gibril
with 600 wings
obviously muhammad did not see an angel
he was seeing something else
maybe a spaceship it is extremely
deceptive how cp brings up only a
portion of ibn kathir stevzir he shows
the explanation of the two
three and four wings aya on the screen
but refuses to scroll down where the
ayah is fully interpreted
now the most important part here that
you have to notice is this first of all
to assume that the statement two and
three and four implies that the angels
cannot have more wings
is a fallacy this is because if i said
for example
timmy has two and three and four crayons
i'm not saying timmy does not have more
than four the proof for this is the fact
that i'm using the word and
between all the numbers mentioned in the
sentence if i wanted to say
that timmy only has two or three or four
crayons
i wouldn't have used the word and
between the numbers
second of all the ayah should be read in
its entirety because it solves this
question
the rest of the ayah says
yasha
in translation he increases in creation
whatever he wills
indeed allah is over all things
competent
now this sentence itself explains how
allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
increases things in their creation so
allah subhanahu ta'ala
can't make an angel have more than four
wings
in fact if cp actually scrolled down a
little bit and honestly read fully what
ibm kathir said
he'd see that ibn kathir quotes a
scholar called a suddhi
who literally says that the increase has
the following meaning
quote he increases their wings and
creates them as he wills but you know
crazy uncle
pringles literally holds the screen for
like 10 minutes and refuses to scroll
down
and you know what the worst thing is
guys this live stream
lasted for three hours
three freaking hours imagine if i
actually bothered myself
with watching the whole screech show
look let me give you some advice
crazy uncle pringles get a real job
and pray to god that somebody does not
report you
to the police for intimidating a girl
online
and demanding naked pictures from her
quoting you whether she likes it or not
thus constituting you as a potential
rapist and harm for society
as was demonstrated by brothers hijab
and farid on muhammadi jobs channel
as for you guys may allah bless you and
keep you firm
and always smiling in the face of idiots
but even if you are the only woman in
the world i will not do breastfeeding
for when you from yours come back
you must women are full of aids and now
i want you to focus with me we arrive to
the mother
finally you will give me you will give
me your breasts do you like it or not
your promise
here's a funny clip of cp lying about
the black stone
now the black stone in makkah is one of
cp's favorite topics
the prince of deception himself often
argues that it is proof that muslims are
polytheists
cute anyhow in this video he speaks
about the historical
narrative surrounding the black stone
what was people use people to go around
the black stone
and kiss it and lick it before it's like
you mean the black stone is yeah
the thing which is uh near in the cab
yeah the one looked like a vagina
okay yeah yeah is it true that people
before islam they used to go
and they touch it and they kiss it and
they lick it and even they put their
penis inside it and the
woman they put their hands full of blood
inside
actually saying something that's not
true about it okay what if i
do you want to challenge me to prove it
to you say actually
no you can't prove it to me you can
prove it to me that's they think
what you're saying is actually can you
give me like can you give me like a
month from now so i can find the
reference
don't worry cp isn't going to let us
wait for a whole month he actually will
share the report in a second
he's just playing hard to get
anyways there are two inaccuracies in
the previous clip the first is him
saying that men stick their sexual
organs
into the black stone this is a claim
that cannot be supported and cp will not
even
attempt to support the second
claim is that women used to smear it
with their menstrual blood now the text
does not say this and i will be giving
cp the benefit of the doubt
since his arabic is quite weak so let's
just carry on
when cp actually provides the report
that supports his position
does it say that there
does it say that the black stone became
a black because women
they used to touch their vagina with it
he hang up
[Laughter]
now here we have the second lie cp
argues that women
touch the black stone where their sexual
organs the text does not say this at all
the text says it was touched by a
lord in the pre-islamic era and turned
black
this word that cp translated to vagina
cannot mean that earlier in the video he
said that women would smear their blood
on it
according to his argument there this
term would be read as
heid in other words when menstruation
touched the black stone it turned black
now there's a stupid reading and
translation but at least
he wasn't intentionally lying
translating the term as
vagina though is an outright lie
the correct way to read this word
is meaning
when women who were on their periods
touched it
it turned black now unlike cp's
translation this sentence
at least makes some sense linguistically
either way either way either way guys
this report doesn't even have a chain of
narrators and is disconnected
by at least 450 years so no
this report is a rejected one
did you enjoy the little lesson
crazy uncle prince i am a scholar you
are a donkey
philosophy enthusiasts good morning guys
how are you guys doing
hope you're all good and yes i'm
actually doing this in the morning
my god so cp makes the claim that we
believe a lie is freaking physical
let's get into it
okay what happened now to the first
shape
muslim you see allah he come to them in
other shape
correct this is what he's saying okay
what happened to the shape before it
uh of course he changes
it's not i don't think it's like a
physical thing
no no my friend allah is a physical no
yeah but just like energy changes form
it doesn't have to be someone going
inside
something first of all let us come to an
agreement
are you saying allah is not a physical
being
um something we can't compare of course
not no no allah is a physical being you
can go and watch my debate with many
scars all of
the agree that allah is a physical being
all the muslims agree
allah is a physical being and he have no
spirit there's so much stupid in this
video that i don't know where to begin
first of all mr pringle says that all
the scholars that he spoke to believe a
lie is physical
i mean so what this is false because
when it comes to the majority of the
muslims
this is not the case according to imam
at tahawi rahimahullah
his standard creed which is approved of
by the vast majority of the muslims
historically says that allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala is not encompassed by the six
directions
now although muslims differ on the exact
meaning of these words
what both asha'aris and salafis agree
upon is that allah wa ta'ala is not
encompassed by anything and that allah
is absolute
which means that he's indivisible or
indivisible sorry
not made of parts or components in
accordance with the ayah from surah
al-ikhlas
allah this means that allah cannot be
divided into lengths
and this would mean that he is without a
doubt non-physical
in any muslim creed essentially though
cp argues that a physical thing is a
thing that changes
or a thing that has an image due to the
hadith that we're going to read
but this is not true as there are
realities which change
that are non-physical such as mental
states
anger and happiness are not physical but
at the same time
the human being's soul changes through
these states
similarly even if we are to accept
hypothetically that allah is changing
although this is against one of the
points of imam tahawi's standard creed
as well
it would not render allah physical
now when it comes to the hadith that he
quotes he reads the translation of the
word
surah to mean shape with all due respect
to
sunnah.com but this translation is
inaccurate the word for shape in arabic
is
shaklun and not suratun although suratun
can be used for pictures and a similar
the standard meaning of surah
though is the image of someone
now let's see what the hadith says
foreign
in translation allah will come to them
in a
image other than they know and will say
i am your lord
they will say we seek refuge with allah
from you
this is our place we will not follow you
till our lord comes to us
and when our lord comes to us we will
recognize him
then allah will come to them in an image
by the way remember
the reason why i said this is this means
image
in an image that they know and will say
i am your lord
they will say no doubt you are our lord
and they will follow him and then a
bridge will be laid
over the hellfire so there's two ways of
explaining this
as most of you guys probably know the
most popular akita schools or movements
right now in the muslim world are the
ashari maturity
and atharian salafi movements now the
ashari's in mathuridis
would have one answer to this and the
ataris and salafis
a different one and what they both have
in common though is
negation of allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
being physical and here's how
as you mentioned imam tahawi's creed is
generally used as a standard creed of
the muslims
when it comes to the salafi and athari
interpretation of this
hadith this is quite simple utterance of
these creeds will simply say that allah
comes
in whatever way befits his majesty and
that he appears in different images in
whatever way befits his majesty
what they mean by this is that they
confirm what is found in the text
but the modality of the reality of these
attributes of allah or allah himself
is known to allah alone to start
describing
how this coming or jaya of allah is
in the sense of it being a physical
movement would be considered
a biddah a condemned innovation in these
schools
as for the asharis and mathuridis
atterns of these creeds
would say that the words used in hadiths
such as this one
describe a reality whose meaning is
consigned
now what do they mean by this well
basically when we say the word
to come or the word image this is often
not
associated with something physical so
for example
we can say the time has come to
the same word ja would be used even
though we know that the word ja'a
can be used for physical coming it is
clearly not talking about something
physical here
but rather the appearance of an event
that was anticipated
similarly the scholars of these two
creeds the ashari and the mathuridi
would simply say that allah subhanahu
ta'ala coming to the believers
has the meaning of non-physical
manifestation of who he
is and his attributes when it comes to
the word
sora or image this too can be used in a
non-physical sense
so for example if we're talking about
somebody's character we can say
this doesn't fit your image what we mean
by this
is this does not fit your reputation i.e
it is not coherent with your character
or we can say something like this the
image that you're giving off is good
which essentially means that we're
saying the example you're setting for
people
is good there's many more examples of
how the word
image can be used for non-physical
reality
so when it says in the hadith that allah
would appear in one image and then in
another
all this means is that allah will make
manifest his reality in different ways
to the believers and this can happen by
simply
what the asharis would say putting an
accident of awareness of allah and his
attributes
in the believers
this does not mean that a lot changes
though because of the fact that an
observed thing is not changed by the
virtue of being observed
if i was standing in a place eternally
and then somebody walked past me to look
at me if i still didn't move i wouldn't
change
so this would be the asha'ari and
maturity explanation and allah knows
best indeed
allah has no spirit actually i just
opened the
fatwa here yes you see
there's a guy he's debating with with
the uh with the christians like me
and he's asking if allah has a spirit
he is debating with the christians and
is asking does allah has a spirit have a
spirit
the answer no the answer allah
the spirit or soul is not one of the
attributes of allah
rather it is one of the things have been
created by allah
so allah has no spirit okay so if allah
is not spirit he's not a physical being
so what he is
[Laughter]
that that means not exist because
nothing left
you have no other options you know what
i mean yeah okay
okay so he is not a spirit and now what
is left he's a physical being
we say about allah that he's the
necessary
being and pretty much all monotheistic
philosophers
agree on this uh this is a false
dichotomy fallacy that christian prince
is setting up here
to make it seem as if the only options
are a physical being or a spiritual
being
despite the fact that there are mental
states
there are possibilities of contingent
existences that don't have
shapes and forms uh time itself
is not something that has a shape or a
form or a physicality and yet it exists
so this is a huge false dichotomy
fallacy
and cp refuses to accept the fact
subconsciously that he has no idea about
theology anyways i think that that's it
guys
uh my last fun hotel forgive me if i
misrepresented
any of these schools of creed and
i hope you guys have a blessed evening
everyone this is perhaps one of
cp's most awkward videos get your kids
out of the room
i'm serious i'm not going to be
responsible for this one
bismillah our problem chapter 33 verse
number 15. here we go
here we go and this is only a privilege
to muhammad only only a privilege to
muhammad any believe in women and any
believe women
who dictate her panty to the prophet
if the prophet wished to with her she
doesn't say you know it says to to sleep
with her
and this is only for thee not for the
believer
isn't it obvious that this is a corrupt
verse made by the corrupt man muhammad
for the benefit of muhammad
who is the only one who get the benefit
of this privilege muhammad
for those curious you will realize by
returning to commentaries that the
verse is referring to the prophet peace
be upon him being allowed
to get married without paying a dowry
cp has a completely different
interpretation
which is much more than just
interpretation rather it's just
an outright lie this is what it says
this is about those are those are the
of muhammad they are they are not
his wives they are offering themselves
for sex
first lie cpr use of the verse is saying
that this ruling is a free pass for the
prophet peace be upon him to have sex
with whomever he likes
the text does not say this and we can
see quite
clearly that the re that the verse is
referring to marriage that's not a sense
this
is what it says any women she can give
herself a prophet and not only that
muhammad hold on after that muhammad he
starts receiving ugly women they want to
sleep with him and muhammad you look at
them they are disgusting
so look what he did he made the verse
right after it he says
though mays defer who you know
the one the one who turned away from him
or the one who choose so muhammad he can
okay let us say you come to him you
don't like how you look like maybe
you're older
so he say okay oh oh this is too much
too many movement they are coming to
sleep with me
so what i will do now so he made the
verse says that allah told me
i might choose and i might delay the one
later later you know later so muhammad
has given himself more excuse
to use and abuse women because there's
many ugly women they start coming to
muhammad and the reason they want to
sleep with him
because if they stay with muhammad they
will be considered as women of muhammad
and that mean they will have a free food
forever they will have a retirement plan
they will have respect to the believers
because that's it they are
the excuse my language they are the
bishops of muhammad
second lie by cp there is no evidence
for his claim that this has to do with
unattractive women
this is nothing more than an outright
lie the
previous verse verse 50 doesn't even
state that it is an
obligation upon him to have intercourse
with every woman that approaches him
for verse 51 to be introduced as an
alleged cop-out
um of course i'm referring to cp's
sinister interpretation
lady do you see what it says here yes
thank you
yes i continue verse and you speak
arabic don't you
okay so does it continue does it
continue yes or no am i lying
it's i ing to f her this is not to marry
her
mary you marry only once
the prophet wishes to read her what is
that what is with her there's no with
her here
okay in arabic means marriage no no let
me show you here we go
i will show you from your islamic
islamic website what is the nikah mean
give me a second here we go
we don't make things up lady
the third lie by cp is that the term
yesten
does not mean to wed in fact the common
usage of the term is tinker
is too wet his denial of this and
preference of
to have intercourse is one that is
hate driven cp will be refuting himself
shortly by the way
in islam marriage is not restricted of a
platonic
relationship between a husband and wife
nor it is
solely uh for propagation
the islamic term of marriage is nikah
do you see it literally literally means
sexual intercourse so marriage
is about that very seriously i'm not
saying that it's you who's saying that
there's no there's no marriage in islam
you don't use the word marriage you say
the effort
we as an arab christian we use the word
zawash
you as a muslim you use nikah the f word
it's quite funny how cp seems to think
that he's found something here that's
useful for him
it doesn't matter if the origin of a
word
is used in a way if the common usage of
the term
has changed imagine this scenario
a contracting company purchases a crane
for one hundred thousand dollars
after making the purchase the salesman
pulls out a dead crane from behind the
desk
the contractor says what the heck is
this
the salesman a middle-aged grumpy arab
christian responds
i am a scholar you are a donkey the
salesman is arrested for fraud and the
people rejoice
yay the end there's none
he stepped with many women but there's
none of them became his wife because
it's what it was just for fun
fourth lie i don't even need to comment
on this
this is a baseless claim by cp you are
let us say you are walking i'm not
insulting you by the way don't take it
as personal
let us say you are walking in front of
muhammad and he saw you he liked you
according to islam
if his eyes fear unto you which means he
saw you he like you
your husband he have to divorce you
immediately
so muhammad cannot sleep with you
let us see what caller
this is quran interpretation for that
verse
you know arabic that will make it a lot
easier for me do you see in front of you
on the screen the arabic
do you see it sarah
do you see the arabic i see it
okay does it say either
how disgusting that is you just said you
don't accept that
if he if muhammad he look at you and he
like you
your husband must divorce you
immediately
so the prophet he can with my respect to
you he can sleep with you
fifth lie cp makes the claim that this
is
according to islam and that's just the
way it is
now in reality it's a fringe opinion
that seems to have
only been attributed to al jueni
the source that cp provides is iblarabi
who actually points
readers to a previous section in his
commentary
where he actually refutes this report
and points out that it's weak this is
the interpretation for the quran
it says it clearly that if the prophet
of allah his eyes fall into a woman
her husband he must immediately divorce
the women so the prophet he can if her
immediately the sixth
and seventh lie there are two lies here
as i've just mentioned
cp is using a false report from the zaid
and zaineb
matar to argue this point cp claims that
this has to do with intercourse outside
of marriage
and that this should occur immediately
however the text that cp is referring to
clearly states that the prophet peace be
upon him got married to zainab
not had intercourse outside of marriage
also the marriage didn't occur
immediately but it occurred
after the waiting period of three months
why i know but can you tell me
where which chapter in the quran that is
so i can't
read it for myself this is the same
chapter we are talking about
lydia i know you are not listening to me
this is the same chapter listen this is
this is the same
chapter chapter 33 verse number 50.
eighth lie so here is a screenshot of
verse
50 from chapter 33 cp is arguing that
this chapter states that if the prophet
peace be upon him finds a wife
attractive
then the husband has to divorce his wife
now can you find that being said in this
verse
and there you have it folks this is
probably the most sexually frustrated cp
video that i've come across oh
it wasn't easy so yeah i'll see you guys
in the next one
assalamu alaikum they are the of
muhammad
you see the gang these you see the gangs
they say like excuse my language they
want to use a bad word
but you should respect the dead i mean
let them let them rest in peace
i am not i'm not respecting him this guy
obviously he is
i'm not talking about your dad what your
dad
yes um so i was
watching this video earlier where
christian prince as usual
brings up this point it's about the
relationship between
zaid and zainab and how eventually
zainab became the wife of the prophet
peace be upon him
and he often he often brings up this
point it's nothing new but
in this specific video the caller does
something
which was quite refreshing he simply
asks him
is this authentic let's see how cp
responds
she was white and beautiful of the woman
of quraysh
so i think it means that he liked her he
said subhanallah
and he said uh praise god the the
changer of hearts
and then he he heard zainab
it says that muhammad he went to the
house of his own son
and the wife was there alone and you're
a prophet he flirt with her
speaking loudly to the point she heard
him saying
that praise be to allah the one who
flipped my heart for you
and it says they are for hawiha which
means he fell in love with her
correct yeah
okay is that a trustworthy if your
father come to your house
and your wife she is alone and he said
to her flirting words
like you are sexy you mean i like you
wow yummy
huh if you say such a thing god forbid
is your father
or even if he is your friend or even if
he is your brother
is that a trustworthy person
uh wait this hadith like uh is it uh
is it a weak one is it a weak one what's
that guys is it a weak one
come on man be honest this is alcor to
be this is your islamic website the
kingdom of saudi arabia
the serial killer to be i have nothing
to do with it this is a story written by
muslims about muslims from muslims about
their prophet
there's no way if the muslim wrote this
about their prophet so imagine how ugly
the truth is
now what cp doesn't want you to know
is if you actually scroll down
slightly this is what you will find what
will be saying
as for what has been narrated that the
prophet peace be upon him desired zainab
the wife of zade and some shameless
people
refer to it as a passion then this
can only come from someone that is
ignorant
of the infallibility of the prophet
peace be upon him or one
who thinks little of his sanctity so
actually this means that rejects this
report
the same source that cp is
putting up on a pedestal is rejecting
the report that he's presenting
so what does this say about cp
what does it say about his methodology
what does this say about his
deception when he's dealing with his
audience
ah yeah we we we're almost at the finish
line
let's keep on doing this let's see how
far we can go
what's said i'm like out loud hallelujah
a happiness in the kingdom of god
by now most of us are quite used to cp
lying about islam
it seems to be all that he talks about
in his debates after all
but in this video we find a rare glimpse
of cp lying about christianity
he does this while inviting a muslim to
christianity
in order to accept the divinity of jesus
jesus is anti-selfishness
serve others so you can be served when
jesus he said to his followers i want to
wash your feet they said to him what are
you talking about you our god
how you can wash our feet they refuse he
said to them if you don't let me do it
you don't belong to me now as we can see
in the verses that speak of jesus in the
whole
feet washing event the disciples do not
make that objection
they do not refer to him as their god
cp purposefully injects his ideology
into the texts
in order to win a point for christianity
so why does cp do this doesn't he
believe
that the divinity of jesus and the bible
is
clear man
i'm not gonna do the lengthy intro this
time let's just get to it
you have muslims who are uh falling
and following his his narrations
and you have muslims who don't follow
his narrations
so you don't follow this uh no no you
don't you're yourself
yeah i don't like him too actually
because you know as i know yes
he used to accompany the prophet just to
eat good food i mean this guy obviously
is a says
you know to me it sounds like a nut case
i know actually it says in the hadith
that we use to accompany the prophet
just to eat good food
he said that what is he saying
was with the prophet and bukhari was
being with the prophets that he could
eat what kind of allah is this everyone
knows that al-bukhari was born
a hundred and like 80 years or something
190 years after the prophet peace be
upon him
what the hell is he talking about that's
such a filthy
liar i'm just messing around guys
he's not lying he's not like he's just
yeah and he he confuses he confuses
people he's muskin
he's a senile old man that's been
sitting in front of the
screen for too long what the cp is
trying to say
is that abu hurairah was doing these
things
now what's funny about this is that uh
cp is confused between the names
because i mean their names sound exactly
alike
innocent mistake what i'm trying to
point out is
that cp um i'm a fair judge
i'm a fair judge of cp's mistakes i'll
call a mistake a mistake
and i'll call a lie a lie and this one
was a mistake it's a dumb mistake that
uh
young muslim kid wouldn't make um but
you know
cp he's masha allah all right
let's get to the actual lie in the video
okay you are the best people
you are the best of people ever raised
up
and then between two bracket for the
benefit of mankind charter 3 verse 110
the best for mankind are those who bring
them with the chain
around their necks till they embrace
islam
what do you think about this huh
i don't see the hadith on the video
on your well it's maybe it's coming
maybe you have a delay
guys is it coming in your side do you
see the hadith in the screen
so based in your explanation islam is a
racist
cult make people believe
that they are better than other people
not only that
allah he gave them a duty to go and kill
and enslave and put the chains around
the necks of people
in order supposedly to save them from
hellfire
very nice of you you know you come and
you put a chain around my neck
and you drag me like a dog or a donkey
and that because you're a good guy
you take me into slavery because you're
a good guy
because you want to save me is this
hadith
well obviously it is
well can i see it like i want to see the
here we go i'm showing it to you i don't
see it i don't know
this is the book of riyadh
and the hadith number is 32.
so what do you think
uh
well uh
well well you want to call a friend uh
i don't i don't agree with you don't
agree with your prophet
did you say you don't agree with the
prophet
did you say did you say you don't agree
with the prophet
it's not that i think this this hadith
is like
like maybe the it's like it was it was
it was wrongly
like what's it called the trans
transmission
there was like the transmission you see
before i used to have a car older than
this one my car now is like 15 years old
but i used to have an older one the
transmission it was very
what the transmission my friend this is
your prophet this is your books this you
this is your muslims are the one who is
saying that it's not me
where is uh the name of the prophet
peace be upon him this hadith
is this hadith from rasulullah or is
hadith
so i'm confused here
so according to uh cp our prophet is
called abu hurairah
but i thought that al-bukhari was abu
hurairah so is al-bukhari our prophet
well uh cp you need to take a break bro
you need to take a break
this is the lie this is the lie right
here
saying that this is something said by
rasulullah
it wasn't said by rasulullah all right
so chill dude
now well that's all i have to say sit
down
i am a scholar you are a donkey
in this video we're going to be looking
at one of cp's favorite topics
the kissing of the black stone which he
considers to be an act of polytheism
let's check it out you have a guy his
name is um
he got you you and your prophet busted
because he said
i know that this stone is useless and
harmless
is that correct yeah i yeah i know that
okay why muhammad did not rebuke umar
and he says to you
he says to him why why you are saying
it's useless
when i say it it is it is used why you
say that it is harmless
when i say it can harm first lie the
prophet peace be upon him never said the
words
the black stone is useful and harmful
and cp is claiming that he did because
he believes that the prophet peace be
upon him said that touching it erases
one's sense
now cp is trying to force a
contradiction
between the stance of the prophet peace
be upon him and your um stance
by attributing these words to the
prophet in reality the prophet peace be
upon him
also held the belief that the black
stone is an inanimate
object hence it cannot be a benefit
or a harm in end of itself
why he did not rebook him i will tell
you why because muhammad was a coward he
didn't dare to rebook
omar second lie the prophet peace be
upon him didn't
rebuke omar because there is no conflict
between the two positions
even if there was a conflict he wouldn't
be able to rebuke him
because he was dead
and omar is leading the pilgrimage in
this report
so when when umar he say that this is a
useless stone
muhammad is simply simply saying
muhammad is a liar
third lie as we can see from the same
report or what actually kisses the stone
so no he didn't consider the prophet
peace be upon him to be a liar
you have a major campaign his name is
getting your prophet busted and
getting all the muslim busted that they
are nothing but pagans
doing an act of paganism fourth lie
again umar did not bust anyone
he himself saw nothing wrong
with kissing the black stone and kissed
it himself
and there you have it why muhammad did
not reboot
assalamu alaikum christian prince prides
himself
on being someone that keeps on
surprising us
with new fresh arguments against islam
well i'll admit i have heard some things
from christian prince that i've never
heard elsewhere
but that's not necessarily something to
be proud of
the topic of this video is the changing
of the direction
of prayer this occurred in the second
year
after the migration to medina anyway
check this clip out okay does it say in
arabic
okay does it say here that it shall
please thee
so are you saying from here we conclude
that muhammad was the person that chose
to move
yes it was the choice actually of um not
the choice of muhammad
what so what we will do we get away we
got away with it and look what
the one who choose the one who choose
that
the kaaba is the where we should pray it
was um
read me carefully omar said
my lord agreed with me in three things
one i said o messenger of allah i wish
we took the station of abraham as our
prayer please
all right it was the wish hoof
the first lie is that um was the reason
for the direction of prayer to change
cp quotes a hadith that speaks about the
station of ibrahim
now every muslim has been to makkah and
pretty much almost all muslims know
that the station of ibrahim is this
cased
area right here this has nothing to do
with direction of prayer what does it
mean to take the station of ibrahim as a
prayer place
well it means to pray right here
but here we notice
[Music]
here we notice here we notice something
very funny about your prophet
you're a prophet trying to copy the jews
trying to be one of them
for a certain time when the jews
rejected him and they he
was not able to successful to make
anyone convert to islam
so he decided to dump that idea and
accept the idea of omar
omar he got a better idea the second lie
there were jews that accepted islam
perhaps the most famous of them was
abdullah bin salam who was one of the
rabbis
also notice how cp argues that the
muslims changed their direction because
the jews didn't accept islam
he's going to contradict himself in a
bit why you're a prophet to change the
direction of
jerusalem we found the answer he copied
from
i have a better idea what is the idea
the kaaba the kaaba let me tell you what
happened
when when hold on hold on hold on
hold on oh
hold on hold on when when muhammad he
killed all his enemies and he killed the
jews
business is dead people they fear
being poor third lie a little while ago
cp said that the direction of prayer was
changed because the jews didn't accept
islam
now cp is saying that it changed because
they killed all the jews and the muslims
didn't have money
this leads us to the fourth lie which is
that the muslims
didn't kill all the jews in medina but
for more on that topic refer to the link
in description below
also don't forget that the event of the
changing of the prayer
occurred in the second year after the
migration
so all the jews were
still in medina at the time
so muhammad he listened to allah
advice if we make the ka'ba a place of
hajj
a place of station like las vegas of
muslims
imagine how many people they will come
and spend their money
and that was the whole idea fifth lie
omar never said such a thing
keep in mind that makkah was under
control
of the polytheist meccans at the time
and remember the polytheist meccans
are the enemies of the muslims why why
would umar try to make money for the
pulvists
that is just dumb it's just so dumb all
right guys
i'm out take cares
this video is one of the first videos
that i've watched by cp
um i took down some time stamps that i
wanted to verify
later but i just never got to it this
debate is
quite a treat since it's between cp and
ashik that studied at lazhar
yes the azhari sheikh was
at times it was like he had little to
nothing to say
my guess is that it's because he it's
because he was shocked
by some of the information that cp was
presenting to him
of course upon fact checking cp's
material
we come to realize that he was lying
through his teeth as usual
and he was using that to catch his
opponent
off guard the topic of the discussion
was
also known as temporary marriages cp is
arguing that quran chapter 4
verse 24 is about muta the azhari sheikh
denies this
let's hear what cp has to say
it says that this is and i can give you
a ton of them i mean
it's really strange you are saying to me
give me one person saying that when all
of them they agree that this is about
muta
can you give me one did not say this is
about zawaj mutta i i'm really
i'm amazed of you saying that so this is
cp's first lie he claims that no scholar
said that 4 24 is about muta we will
soon see
how he is lying when pressed
to provide an example of a quranic
commentary that rejects 4 24
as a verse of mata he quotes
cp then responds this is the
lucy and i did not mention it to it
right away
because i was waiting for you to insist
you insisted that lucy he said this is
not about muta
but the fact that lucy he says the
opposite it's in front of me
it says in front of me
translate and it's been said that this
verse is about the muta
which is to do nuka for a preset time
to one day or more
so you said to me lucy you don't agree
that this is a lucy says this is not
mutha
i told you remember can you give me one
scholar don't agree that this is the
muta
you said to me this is lucy lie number
two
cp argues that lucy says that 4 24 is
about mutha
he reads a statement that says it
has been said that this verse is about
muta however this is not lucy's opinion
the azhari sheikh then exposes cp
this little clip is kind of funny it
seems
quite clear that the azhari sheikh is
reading from a book
since cp already changed the screen i do
feel that cp removed the screen
intentionally
in order to not allow him to catch the
part where
lucy refutes him here is the little clip
of him changing the screen
before passing the mic
and when he say allah forbid the muta
he mean the quran where is that we can't
be found come on
whoa whoa whoa slow down cp
we need to get you busted
anyhow the text translates to
the view that this verse was revealed
about mutta
is wrong anyways let's get back to cp's
other lies
so my friend the scholar you mentioned
to me agree with me
al-kortubi agree with me atabari agree
with me if nicother
agree with me who agree with you nobody
lie number three
cp claims that tabari said that this
verse is about
here's a screenshot from tabari stepsier
he says
and the more accurate of the two views
is that this
is to be understood as those that you
get married to
then have intercourse with then pay them
referring to the dowry line number four
cp claims that ibn kethir said that this
verse is about muta
this is false as well here is a
screenshot
ibn kit actually says mujahid said that
this is about mutta but the majority of
scholars are against this
and there you have it but i mean what do
i know
i'm not a scholar i am a scholar you are
a donkey
rahman raheem assalam alaikum
how are you guys doing so today
cp fails to read anything in the name of
god
and here's how the you know uh for us
we say what when it's wrong we say it's
wrong
there's in arabic there's nothing it's
called bism it is always be
ism and this is why in the quran if we
search right now the word bisim
we will find it only appear
when the muslims are doing this
recitation for this verse the reason no
cp the basmala is not a verse the only
time when it could be a verse
is when it is read in the fatiha but
there's even debate on whether that is
true or not
there's debate on whether the basmala is
the first ayah of the fatiha
or it's just read before the first ayah
of the fatiha reason for that
the muslim explain in their own website
for it is
easier for because we repeat it a lot
all right yeah because if we if we take
if we take
uh uh if we take this and we translate
exactly in google translation let us
search for google translation
let us go and open google translation
you know that a person has no idea about
a language when they have to resort to
google translate
google freaking translate here they are
saying that the letter alif
the reason it was not deleted for the
lack of use which means
if the word is not used too much in the
quran
we are talking about the word be ism
there's no such thing as bisum no arab
ever said that
bism would not even be one word it would
be you dividing two words
ism which means name and b which is a
harf
a preposition and this preposition has
the meaning of with
you would be dividing these two words
apart
the word which is not used too much in
the quran it was not deleted the letter
alif because
because of the lack of use so because
that
word in the front of the name of allah
muslim they have to repeat it all day
long
then they had to delete it to make it
easier to read
so in order to be saying be ism which is
hard to recite and to sing the quran
because remember the muslim they
they sing the quran so when they sing it
if they want to say
it's not good so this you know so to
make the song nice or they deleted
letters from the quran so first of all
cp claims that we as muslims
historically remove the alif from the
basmata
so that it can be easier to read
ironically the same text that he holds
on the screen refutes him
because he speaks of the expression
which is found in surah 96 surah
which is literally the first piece of
revelation in this expression or rather
in this ayah to be even more precise
the alif is written and why is that so
well the same text the cp has
opened and that he just read partially
in front of us
says it is
unlike his words read in the name of
your lord
because it i.e the letter alif is not
removed
due to the small amount of istiyamal of
usage
so in other words the aleph remains
because the expression
bismi rabbika is not used often and
another thing that we can notice here
is that despite the fact that the lf is
found there we still say
bismi combined we don't separate the
preposition from the noun b is me we
don't say that because there's a rule in
arabic grammar
that when two short vowels meet each
other that are separate like this like b
and ism then they will combine and
become a sila
a connection in phonetics they'll become
bismi
so in other words for example we can
have another word like eben if i want to
say
to the son of someone even mean son if i
want to say to someone's son
i would say lebanon i wouldn't say the
ibn
this is a rule in arabic grammar but
really the main point is guys
had the muslims really wanted to remove
the alif so that the
expression can be pronounced easier they
would have done the same thing in surah
96 which is simply not the case the alif
is still found there
and yet we pronounce it bismi the same
way that we pronounce
bismillah rahmanir rahim we pronounce
bismi rabbika
right it's really simple as that anyways
hope you guys enjoyed that
your tiny brain wipers of other people's
bottoms
if you do not open this door we shall
take this castle by force
in the name of god and the glory of our
right that settles it yes
and we are finally here at july
number 100 i was thinking of stopping at
99 but i had the feeling that if i did
christian prince would claim that it is
proof for the trinity
your god have 99 names this is the exit
which means 33 the age of jesus 63 the
father the son the holy spirit
in this video i'm going to be sharing my
thoughts on cp's
lie about what he calls sahih ibn majjah
i previously exposed the slide before
but
i felt like it deserved a video on its
own
the first thing that you need to be
aware of is that there are hundreds of
works on hadith literature
out of them six were singled out and are
referred to
as the six books these six books were
authored by the bukhari muslim abu dhabu
eternity and ibn maja
the first of the two books are called
the sahih
meaning the two authentic collections
the other four
are referred to as
sunan is plural for sunna
the sahihan
were authored with the intention of
being authentic collections
the four sunnah were authored with the
intention of collecting the reports of
the prophet peace be upon him
his actions his statements
his description but these reports
sometimes do include weak chains
the authors of the four books never
stated that their works
include only authentic reports in fact
all four of them sometimes comment on
individual hadiths as weak
take this report for example where ibn
maja states
that this specific report has no
foundation
now this is where christian prince comes
in
he's quite aware that the weakness of
reports makes his life harder
since he won't be able to use a lot of
his arsenal
against islam previously when i called
him out on this
he responded with a video claiming that
ibn maja's book
is fully authentic and that it is called
sahih ibn majjah why you muslim even
writing the hadith if it's a lie
if this is a lie why it's in the book
it's called sahih ibn imagi
guys the name of the book the correct
hadith
however that is not the name of the book
now why would cp lie about such a thing
why would he change the name of a book
christian prince is a desperate
individual that does not respect
the intellect of his fanbase and sadly
a lot of the times it seems like they
don't have much self-respect
either with that said i'm done with the
series
100 lies by christian prince i wouldn't
have been
able to do this with such ease with
other critics of islam
not even with atheist critics
that just shows how low of an individual
christian prince really is a message
to the non-muslim viewers this series
isn't about proving that islam is true
it is about proving that christian
prince
your lord and savior is a liar
i know it hurts but that's just the
reality of the matter
some of you will be objective enough to
realize this
heck some of you have already realized
this when i was on the third episode in
the series
most of you will most likely dismiss
everything i've said and done
due to your emotions clouding your
judgment
in any case i'm done for now
muslims please share this playlist with
friends of
christian prince and let the world know
how deceptive he is i wouldn't be here
without you guys
too